it smells kind of gross but for saving
the planet so that's the primary 40% of
food goes uneaten by Americans every
year Americans are throwing away one
hundred and sixty five billion dollars
in food every year meanwhile 42 million
Americans 13 million of which are
children don't have access to enough
food to maintain a healthy lifestyle
Emeril I'm a tasty producer here in New
York and hearing all of those facts is
terrifying
so what are we gonna do about it here in
New York we have eight active tasty
producers that are regularly filming and
testing recipes so we go through a lot
of food and that means a lot of food
scraps end up in the trash so for the
past week I collected all of the food
waste we produced and I weighed it 61
pounds that number is so scary because
if you multiply that by that's two
thousand nine hundred and twenty-eight
pounds a year that's a lot of food waste
I can't help but think there's more we
can do about it
I am here today because I'm challenging
our tasty producers to produce zero food
waste for seven days both in work and at
home
oh man that sounds difficult like what
is it in the tail though while you're at
work and while you're at home instead of
throwing your scraps away you're gonna
be composting everything and also like
just be more mindful about how much food
you're ordering how much food you're
using for shoots so will you pledge to
take this challenge with your signature
all right fine yeah easy let's do it no
like blood pledge that's later I can't
do that on camera it's gonna be
challenging but I think it'll be really
rewarding it's a good challenge this
positivity is honestly gonna make me so
emotional after spending the morning
hunting everyone down I finally got all
of them to sign away their rights to
waste any food for the next week it
would be impossible to cook the amount
of food that we do and come out of it
with zero food byproducts so I
encouraged producers first and foremost
to limit their intake of food to only
what they need and to give away any
extra food to those in need or those
even around the office composting was
only supposed to be used as a last
resort so I've tasked myself with eating
this Apple as little waste as possible
I'm gonna compost it and I feel so much
better about myself it's crazy so I have
this extra batch sweet potato hummus
instead of throwing it out I'm going to
save it and maybe a snack tomorrow I
decided the most foolproof way to ensure
we would consistently compost in a tasty
kitchen was to organize a compost
program so I decided to take it upon
myself to try and make that happen I
called at least nine different companies
researched all afternoon and talked
about compost for a couple of hours
until I finally found one woman who
seemed like she could help Meredith hi
Meredith my name is Merle I'm I'm
interested in bringing composting to my
my company that I work at awesome that's
great
we talked for 30 minutes about how to
make this happen
toward the end I was feeling pretty
hopeful I think it's gonna happen
Oh Mike that sucks it okay so I'm
waiting to talk to the facility
I'm posting to the office very nervous
but after my phone call yesterday with
Meredith I'm feeling pretty good but I
don't know what she's gonna say so wish
me luck
I just talked to facilities we're gonna
be able to get a compost situation
rolling out for the tasty kitchen just
great news I don't know how this is
happening right now but if you don't
work people we're gonna be composting
it's gonna be great we're gonna
officially have composting in the tasty
kitchen what forever are you serious
this makes it so much easier this is all
I've wanted this entire time because if
you give people the ability and make it
easy for them they'll do it it's just
women it's an inconvenience I was so
happy to see that people were excited at
the idea of having a compost system in
the kitchen so the next step was to have
Meredith come in and talk compost with
us why is composting important everyone
eats
so everyone generates food waste food
scraps go to a landfill they get
suffocated and in that environment which
we refer to as an anaerobic environment
one without oxygen
methane is a byproduct methane is a
greenhouse gas more potent than carbon
dioxide in terms of its warming
potential and it's a pretty easy
solution removing food scraps from our
waste stream to avoid methane production
and to mitigate the further you know
greenhouse gas emissions and climate
change is very important and if we all
can play a part in that process by
putting our food scraps in a separate
bin in our houses why wouldn't we
meredith talked to our producers to make
sure they knew how to properly compost
before she handed over our shiny new bin
I used morels compost bin it really
wasn't hard or scary and I don't know
why I was scared there's no reason not
to be doing it I just gotta say I feel
like the world is a little bit of a
better place now not taking all the
credit I'm taking a little piece of the
credit Ernest said that actually one of
the best ways to reduce food waste is to
eat it so that's what we're gonna go do
is heat some tasty enough yes I forgot
to compost
so here's a lot of stuff that we've gone
through freezing it also helps to keep
the odors at bay when I'm opening and
adding to it also look at how crazy this
is this is a day and a half worth of
compost here we have glorious Union
Square farmers market with what I found
all this calm
just cleaned out my refrigerator and I
filled up one Tupperware container they
put it in a paper bag and walking up to
the farmers market I have some food
wasted i raided the other day by EM
tempting to put them in the composting
bin but I think that maybe I can make
something out of it I managed tomato put
a pretty tasty salad now I'm gonna see
who I can share it with some say of
composting all of these perfectly good
leftovers we're gonna give them away to
people at the office okay
I love my team love them to death but
I'm not a fool I'm gonna check the trash
bins to make sure nothing goes
undetected
[Music]
it's a forge I knew there would be some
slip-ups along the way which is totally
fine and to be expected but they were
not going to elude the trash lady not on
my watch
just like anything else composting needs
to become a habit and soon enough it'll
be second nature so it's time to weigh
any trash that people accidentally
accumulated that would be going to
landfill as a whole the tasty kitchen
looks sparkling clean everyone's done a
fantastic job of trying to keep and use
our produce to its fullest potential and
if not just to give it away we're gonna
compare this number with our number from
last week it was 61 pounds the verdict
is in and we got three and a half pounds
from 61 pounds to three and a half
pounds is amazing I'm so happy for
everyone I'm really proud of us all the
food that goes to waste in the tasty
kitchen I'm just shocked that we weren't
doing this before it's really nice to
know that anything that doesn't get
eaten or that people leave behind that
ordinarily I would just throw away can
be repurposed and in some fashion Kermit
the Frog once said it's not easy being
green but I'm here to tell you oh yes it
is